you aren't at all what people say about
you I don't want to be called blood
anymore so what do you want to be called
hey youtubers it's Charlie so arrow
season 2 is coming back and I thought
I'd talk a little bit about what's going
on with all the characters which new
characters from the DC Universe are
appearing how it's gonna crossover with
the new flash TV show and how
Christopher Nolan ties it all together
so let's get started first things first
let's have a moment of silence for the
death of Captain Jack turns out all I
needed to find peace was the new show ah
just kidding but seriously Malcolm
Merlyn is actually dead on the show they
did confirm that his character will not
be coming back so Jack Harkness will not
be reappearing since he's dead arrow
needed a new villain so Naveed Bob
from homeland is actually guest starring
as al Awad
he's from the League of Shadows so there
will be a League of Shadows connection
in arrow season 2 there are also a ton
of other new cast members that I'm
really excited about - including Summer
Glau shall play Isabel rochev she's
another character from the comics but
like a lot of shows like Game of Thrones
they're changing a few things about her
story just kind of suit the season
she'll be more of a business person
during the season but but I'm guessing
since Summer Glau plays so many action
roles that her character will have
something to do with the League of
Shadows by the end of the season on the
show officially her character will be
running another business trying to take
over Queen industries after the death of
Oliver's father but I'm guessing it'll
be some sort of like a Talia fake-out
and The Dark Knight Rises where a
business person will turn out to have
some sort of evil ties but just to be
clear I'm certain that her character
will not be Talia that character is just
like a little too big and a little too
recent for them to be using it on TV but
I do think that her character will have
ties to the League of Shadows especially
this new Big Bad the other character we
all need to get really excited about is
Black Canary
Caity Lotz will be playing Black Canary
she'll actually be playing the sister of
Laurel a lot of people thought that
Laurel might end up becoming Black
Canary but that looks like it's not the
case I'm guessing there'll be some sort
of love square going on so now you have
Laurel and now Katie lots and the
Huntress from last season's the Oliver's
gonna be juggling a lot of ladies so
this should be really funny this season
but the real big reveal especially at
Comic Con was the fact that the flash is
going to debut on this new season that's
right Barry Allen will become the flash
in episodes 8 & 9 and then they'll use
that character to spin-off a new flash
show next
it's the same creative team and one of
the really cool things is is that
because it's such a big deal it went all
the way up to Christopher Nolan
even though Warner Brothers owns the CW
and all these characters they still have
to have someone okay all these decisions
to use all these big characters so
obviously they can't use Batman and
there's a lot of other characters they
can't use just cuz they're too big like
Superman but because the flash hasn't
really been used in a long time and
because the CW is doing so well with
arrow they really wanted to do a flash
TV show it's just much cheaper and much
easier to get going but if you didn't
know in addition to working on the
Batman franchise and working on the
Superman franchise Christopher Nolan
also became creative director for the DC
Universe as it applies to all of Warner
Brothers movie and TV properties that's
right any time anyone wants to do a
movie or a TV show in the DC Universe
and use a big character or a new
character or do something they haven't
done before or aren't already doing
Christopher Nolan has to take a look at
it there's actually a couple other
people on Hollywood that do things like
this one is JJ Abrams and the other is
Joss Whedon so JJ Abrams owns bad robot
and bad robot does a billion different
TV shows and movies and JJ Abrams and
stuff looking at all of them at some
point even though he doesn't actually
run all these shows and all these movies
and Joss Whedon recently became that for
the Marvel Universe after Avengers
started blowing up all they really do is
just kind of help all these characters
and all these shows work together so
when the show runners wanted to use
Barry Allen on arrow season 2 Warner
Brothers said you have to ask
Christopher Nolan about this and it
turns out Christopher Nolan got really
excited about the idea of Barry Allen on
arrow so you know that if Christopher
Nolan got really excited about arrow
season 2 then you all need to watch it
so when the show comes back I'll be
doing regular episode recaps every week
and reviews I'll be talking a lot about
how the characters are different from
their comic book versions it's just like
when they change things for TV so the
characters are gonna be a little bit
different so it'll be exciting to see
what some of those differences are be
sure to subscribe to get all those
videos and if you really want to help me
up please like and share this video I'll
also be doing a big Game of Thrones
video series that I talked about earlier
this week I'll probably start posting
those videos on Monday it'll talk mostly
about season 4 so I'll get really
excited I'm also working on a divergent
movie preview in The Walking Dead Season
4 video for this week in the meantime
you can learn all about how Joss
Whedon's
killing Avengers than age of Ultron by
clicking here and you can click here to
get my preview for Sherlock season 3
thanks so much for watching see you guys
tomorrow high fives